hello everyone and welcome to the
semi-finals of the American Cup it is
linear Dominguez Perez versus
hikarnakamura this is the second game of
their classical match the the first one
ended in the draw and uh Dominguez Perez
came into the semifinals by defeating
none other than levonne arunan and
Hikaru as we've already seen I made a
video on it defeated Samuel Savion so
this is a wonderful game uh you will
enjoy it let's check it out with Ponte
E4 and Ponta C5 by Hikaru he goes for
the Sicilian Defense Knight to F3 Knight
to C6 and the D4 going for the open
Sicilian uh sorry about that we have sea
captain D for Knight captures and now
Pawn to E5 This Is The Love Intel
variation of the Sicilian uh a little
bit different than what you guys are
used to probably Knight of six Knight to
C3 and then E5 which is the epilicon
variation or the swishnikov variation or
the Alaska variation uh something we've
seen quite a lot even in the world's
Championship matches uh But Here pawn to
E5 right away like I said 11 variation
Knight to B5 with D6 Knight 1 to C3 and
pawn to A6 with Knight A3 and Bishop to
E6 so similar as you would see yeah in
in a session called Knight to C4 and now
Rook the B8 you could go for B5 right
away Hikaru prepares it with Rook B8
Knight to the D5 and now of course you
will not allow this Knight to remain on
such an active Square the bishop capture
spawn captures and now Knight C to E7 we
have Pawn to G3 and here there are a
couple of games that reach this position
Knight to F6 is a known move G6 is a
normal Queen to C7 is a normal but
Hikaru goes Pawn to B5 and it is now as
of move 11 that we have a completely new
game so Knight back to E3 we have Pawn
to G6 preparing to I think get to the
bishop and now Pawn to A4 this is pretty
much always a good move uh when you have
A6 and B5 A4 uh just has to be played so
here are Knight to F6 with eight cappers
on B5 a captures this opens up the uh a
file for the white Rook Bishop to G2 and
now Hikaru doesn't go Bishop G7 but
instead Bishop to H6 why Bishop to
Hidden instead of Bishop to G7 it's hard
to say but you have to be a very strong
player to play to play such a move if
you play it if you're not a strong
player uh you know people would just
look at you weird so here both players
Castle castles castles and now Queen to
D3 we have Knight to the D7 this opens
up uh the uh well the possibility of
Knight coming to C5 which will be an
excellent square but also upon the F5 E4
f for become possible in the future
Bishop D2 We have Knight to C5 now
attacking the queen queen back to E2 and
now Queen to C7
uh making room for the other Rook to
come into the game Pawn to B4 again
pretty much always a a great move for
white here even the top move recommended
by the engine Knight back to D7 and now
Rook the A5 linear goes after the B5
pawn and he covered defends it with a
nice uh nice uh not a tactic but sort of
he defends it with activity Bishop
captures Bishop captures and now Knight
to F5 inviting uh Lanier to capture on
B5 but if he does then Hikaru will play
Queen to C3 and it's a very weird
position maybe giving Hikaru too much
activity then this Pawn is weak this
Pawn is weak uh the Rooks will get
traded off the the other book probably
coming to at the B8 so it would be uh
maybe uh maybe a bit too much even
though the engine says it's perfectly
fine but okay Rook to A7 goes after
hikaru's Queen he covered defense and
now Rook captures on B7 Queen captures
and Bishop back to D2 not allowing the
knights to have this Edge over the
bishop
um it's always unpleasant when your
opponent can always capture your piece
on every move and you can't capture your
opponent's piece on every move then you
constantly have to calculate it and take
that into consideration so just a a very
very nice move we have Rook the A8
Hikaru now activating his Rook Queen to
D3 and now Rook the A2 we have rooked
the D1 and now Knight to F6 uh putting
pressure on that D5 pawn bishop to G5
and now King to G7 with Bishop to H3 uh
putting a lot of pressure on hikaru's
Knights there and now Knight to D4 now
this is a very very unpleasant the C2
Pawn is hanging and okay you can easily
defend it you just Advance it the C3
this is what linear does but now Knight
to C2 and this Knight the C2 Knight
looks uh very odd but it's it's it's
really a great move and you you will
very quickly see why uh here we have
Queen to F3 puts pressure on the Knight
here Hikaru just brings it back Knight
to G8 we have Bishop Dev one and now
Rook the A3 and here all sorts of dirty
tricks become possible like Knight can
come to D4 also Knight can capture and B
for the the queen is now on F3 and
there's no good way to actually deal
with this bishop to C1 was played with
Rook to B3 and now Queen to E4 you have
to give up one of the pawns the the B4
Pawn or the C3 Pawn so Queen to E4 and
now Rook captures on C3 Hikaru wins back
material
uh or rather now he's up upon uh with
Bishop to B2 for this one Pawn uh Lanier
is hoping to grab hold of this diagonal
if he can play F4 and bust open this
diagonal then hikaru's King might be in
trouble Knight to F6 attacks the queen
queen to H4 and here we have rooked the
B3 by Hikaru also a very nice idea was
Knight to D4 and Hikaru most definitely
thought about it and uh he probably
didn't find what what happened after
Rook captures on D4 but here if Rook to
C2 then black is just much much better
uh the The Rook here is hanging and once
you move the Rook back Rook captures on
B2 and uh well this is now a weakness
the D5 Pawn is weak the B4 Pawn is weak
the F2 Pawn will be weak and the bishop
has nothing to do for the entire game
for for the rest of the game this bishop
is just sitting there and the Knight
will have many many squares uh so like
maybe even e for E3 anything can be
placed here for black it's completely
crushing about okay easy to miss work
the B3 was played and now Bishop to C1
with Knight the G8 again covering the H6
Square you do not want any uh
business there uh Queen to d8 now not
allowing the black queen to grab hold of
the C file now the queen is nicely
controlling that and now Queen to E7
Hikaru offers a queen trade Queen back
the A5 goes after the B5 pawn and now
Knights the D4 nicely defending with
Bishop to E3 now Knight to F3 with track
King G2 and queen to F6 defends the
Knight with Bishop to E2 goes after the
Knight and now Pawn to E4 and now okay
Hikaru did open up this diagonal for the
dark Square Bishop but his Knight is
nicely placed on F3 and you can't really
just eliminate it and the win uh win the
black queen because then Queen captures
comes with check then The Rook hangs so
for the moment it's impossible you will
have to move your king to F1 at some
point if you even want to attempt such a
thing so here Queen to after E4 we have
Queen captures on B5 Queen to B2 now
puts pressure on the B4 Pawn also uh on
the bishop you have to be careful not to
blunder it now comes Queen to A6 hoping
to get that B Pawn uh pushed up the
board but now just Knight to F6 Hikaru
could capture on B4 but if he captures
on B4 then you allow Bishop captures
captures and King captures and the white
uh pretty much solved all of his
problems so he's not gonna allow this
and uh as long as the Rook is on the
third rank the the white king can never
get to F3 so Knight to F6 we have pawned
the H3 stopping Knight G4 and now Pawn
to H5 King to F1 now finally hoping to
get this bishop captures on F3 moving
and then the the bishop on this diagonal
might be incredible but now Queen sorry
uh Queen to E5 by Hikaru and now King to
G2 and here Hikaru has a most crushing
moves so feel free to pause the video
and win another game for Hikaru In
classical while I give you a couple of
seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting this a
brilliancy and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it is Rook
captures on E3 that's what Hikaru played
and now you realize what's happening the
G3 Pawn will be weakened and H4 is
coming so there's really nothing to play
here if captures on E3 was played Ponta
H4 and uh even if you play Bishop
captures on F3 it's just not enough just
Queen captures and G3 King F1 now he
captures an F3 threatens Checkmate and
okay you can't stop that but now 94 and
that's pretty much it if you if you move
the Rook then Pawn to F2 is coming and
queen G1 will end the game so instead
after this H4 move G characters and H4
was played but this is even worse now
it's a force mating two Hikaru played
Queen to g a queen to H2 with check King
to F1 or rather maybe even uh yeah I
think a queen to H2 that it was in this
position that linear Dominguez Perez
resigned the game but I will check I
don't want to trick you guys uh yeah it
was in this position that he resigned as
there is nothing more to be done here
once came to F1 is played Queen to G1
will be Checkmate and what what a guy
Hikaru are getting a checkmate with
black In classical chess uh absolutely
incredible stuff so he doesn't just win
the first match in classical against
Samuel Savion he also disposes of linear
Dominguez Perez also in classical time
format uh sure that's how Hikaru
advances to the finals uh the other
matches Wesley still versus Fabiano
caruana I will also cover that match
next so stay tuned for that but yeah uh
a wonderful game hope you hope you guys
enjoyed it I would like to thank Dewey
Tran revision reptiles YouTube Mike
Wagner thought dreams and a very nice
video yesterday for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the Chess World so thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day and if you haven't seen the
Fisher video yesterday do check it out
it's the first link in the description
below see you soon